directement. Jacaudrey
Charbonneau s'est rendu dans un
cégep.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Lundi matin, on est venu au
Cegep de Saint-Jean sur
Richelieu pour discuter avec des
jeunes de 18-19-20-25 ans des
enjeux qui les préoccupent
dans le cadre de la campagne
électorale fédérale.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Combien d'entre vous allez
voter pour la première fois?
Et combien d'entre vous ont
l'intention d'aller voter?
- Moi ça me fait ni chaud ni
froid qu'il y ait des élections
ou pas, mais moi je pense que
pour lui ça va peut-être être
traitre.
- Je trouvais juste qu'on avait
peut-être pas besoin de ça
en ce moment c'est un fardeau
en plus.
- Moi, je comprends un peu
pourquoi il a fait ça... t'sais
la question du passeport
vaccinal, c'est un très bon
sujet à aborder lors des
élections.
- Du côté de la vaccination, on
dirait que j'ai un petit peu un
malaise avec le fait de diviser
la population pis une société ùu
est-ce que c'est comme montré
vos papiers.
- Avec toutes les dépenses que
le gouvernement a fait autant
sur les vaccins que la situation
pour gérer la pandémie.
Tout cet argent là, c'est nous
autres qui allons le payer
au final avec les dettes
les impôts.
- Est-ce que ça vous inquiète la
dette ou c'est quelque chose
d'abstrait?
- Il y a le fond d'urgence qui
va falloir remettre pis ça il va
falloir qu'ils prennent l'argent
ailleurs, fait que oui c'est
moins d'argent dans le système
de la santé. Pis de l'éducation
pis toute ça fait que c'est pas
mal ça qui me préoccupe.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un
d'autres qui veut parler d'un
enjeu?
- C'est sur que moi,
l'environnement qui me préoccupe
le plus. Malheureusement la
majorité des parties qui sont
au pouvoir depuis les dernières
années, ils ne font pas cette
chose au niveau les effets de
serre et tout ça.
- La question de l'environnement
revient souvent. Pour moi
personnellement c'est surtout ça
qui va jouer. À savoir qui veut
faire quoi par rapport à ça.
- Ça commence déjà d'être
l'empire depuis des années. Je
pense que le NPD, ils sont plus
pour leur environnement. C'est
quelque chose qui m'attire
vraiment personnellement.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La pénurie de main vous en
avez entendu parlé?
- Je pense que ça va influencer
mon choix à savoir qu'est-ce
qui se passe avec les
travailleurs étrangers. Moi,
je suis dans l'aménagement
paysager et on fait vraiment
la guerre au manque de main-
d'oeuvre présentement.
En ce moment je suis en génie
mécanique. Je me demande,
est-ce que je me réoriente ou
je continue où est-ce que je
suis parce que ça fait quand
même ça fait 5 ans que je fais
ça fait que j'ai un salaire qui
est rendu très compétitif
comparativement à quand je vais
rentrer sur le marché du travail
en sortant du Cegep.
- Moi, j'étudie en technique de
gestion agricole, c'est sur que
mettons moi quand je pense à ça,
je me dis c'est sur que plus
tard j'ai des travailleurs
étrangers parce que c'est
impossible que j'aille assez
d'employés pour faire tout ce
que j'ai besoin de faire pour
mon entreprise.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le coût de la vie,
l'immobilier, les logements.
Est-ce qu'il y en a qui ont
des choses à dire là-dessus?
- J'ai des amis qui commencent
à aller en appartement.
Ils doivent payer tellement plus
chers qu'avant. Juste acheter
une maison plus tard. Je veux
même pas y penser comment ça va
me coûter cher et devois
m'endettter pour tout ça. Fait
que oui ça me fait un petit peur
le marché immobilier.
♪ ♪ ♪